in these playoffs from downtown Martin
dodging the defensive smart and then
smart Recaps and the shot by Hardin who
has started to gain free of three three
dimes up smart will defend Hardin has
the ball shot clock at seven read the
screen simple away and good oh always on
fire to start Harding has started five
of five but nice start for the Sixers
19-3 advantage
having Grant Williams in because you can
do this Justice switch him on to harden
pardon him Grant Williams the bump the
drive and the floater and James Harden
is now put in 16 points
[Applause]
quad moves picked up by Brown
pardon on the move to tie the game
oh wow kitty pat little crossover finish
at The Rim
Tucker is sitting some vicious screens
out here to free up Maxi playoff screens
right it's a free card hardwood carries
one for the lead that's number five on
Maxine look at that that left arm a
little bit of a push-up but also a nice
acting job there on smart you're right
that matches this
[Applause]
Tatum is there frightening inside
kicking it out Aim Shoot score nice shot
by Harris for three Harden Works around
it drives the defensive portrait
the two seconds game clock in shot clock
pardon sizing up Harford it's a pretty
good oh hardin's got 45. well they got
the switch they wanted Al Horford
Guardian James Harden